everybody welcome to live coding with
Jesse today we're going to continue on
with where we left off in the last
stream so I haven't done any additional
work with that so you haven't missed
anything
I have merged a few pull requests so
we'll go over those quickly ready the
beginning of our first Pomodoro session
and what I want to say oh sorry about
not being able to stream yesterday I did
do a very short stream on my youtube
channel if it was about coding on
blockchain with aetherium and solidity
so just going through a tutorial if
you're interested in in crypto or
blockchain programming like distributed
apps check that out it wasn't a very
good stream at a lot of interruptions
and things but I guess it's a little
introduction to that kind of thing the
link to my channel I think is in the
description of this video so we're gonna
get started soon I'm gonna give
everybody a few more seconds to come in
I'm sure some people are just getting
their notifications that we went live
and hey everyone hey Nicki's in the
middle of working on a pool request for
the routing so iniki's has just added
something to the routing hastily typing
some explanation on the pr and github I
was just looking at that at that pool
request actually so I'll hold off on
that and wait and maybe I'll check it
out later then if you're in the middle
of updating it let's see let me make
sure
all right I got through most of the pull
requests that were open so if you if
you're working on this code or you have
this running you know locally make sure
you do a get pull since some of the code
is just changed literally you know five
minutes ago I was still merging pull
requests okay so up to kind of our
normal normal numbers here so I guess
we'll get started
let me get everything set up we have n
grok up and running already so I'm gonna
paste that in the live chat for you all
so you can click on that link that I
just pasted into the live chat and
you'll be able to see the website as I
work on it and actually there's a new
feature now on youtube so i think the
live chat now gets saved and you can see
the live chat as you watch the replay
so as everything came through you you'll
be able to see it I think that's really
cool I haven't tested it out or anything
I just saw the message that that's
available today so hopefully that'll
work
that'll be really nice for all the other
people watching later on watching the
recordings and let's start our timer so
if you're not familiar with this dream
I'm doing my regular everyday work as a
front-end developer and I do my work in
Pomodoro session so 25 minutes of coding
five-minute break on the stream we do 25
minutes of coding but then during the
five-minute break I answer questions in
the live chat and then at the end
whatever questions are left over I just
take a long break and answer all those
questions so feel free to ask any
questions don't worry if if you're new
you know ask ask
any questions you need to understand I'm
more than happy to explain what's going
on here so let's start this up we are
working with react which is a JavaScript
library
oops I should bring the site over so
everyone can see it huh
there we are and I did say I would show
you some of the pull requests that we
get we have so let me let me show you
we've had just recently I just merged in
these one two three these three by J
Meza Kappa so thank you so much for
those and these were some these are some
UI things that have really been
bothering me but I just didn't really
have the time you know to get to them so
I really appreciate that because I mean
this this really ends up being a big
help you know all these these little
things make a big difference in the
final product like those details you
have no idea how annoying it was unless
you maybe you do if you're trying to
click it when you'd open up the side nav
and try to click here and nothing would
happen or try to click here and nothing
would happen right and you had to click
right on the words for the link to
actually open so I was giving
presentations and I I didn't get it
exactly right and nothing would happen I
said that is not not a great user
experience and definitely wasn't great
during my presentation so that's awesome
so now this whole thing should be a link
awesome and a definite is a link we also
have cursor:pointer now over this icon
to let people know that it's a link
which we didn't have before and we have
some styling on our majors pages that we
were working on before we had
some issues with with the BR tags to
wear on other pages on the news pages we
didn't want them because there are a ton
of BR tags just here and there and
making the formatting look awful well we
actually do want to be our tags as they
are playing an important role on our
major pages so those are the things that
J Meza CAPA
worked on so it really appreciate that
anybody that's interested in submitting
pull requests you're definitely welcome
to if you need some help let me know
don't be afraid to submit something even
if it's your first time submitting I'm
not gonna yell at anybody or get upset
if something's done wrong
sometimes I'll just accept the pool
request and if one or two things need
fixed I'll just fix it after I accept
the pool request
other times I may just point out the
things that need changed and you could
submit the pool request again so this is
very beginner friendly when I help as
many people as I can to you know get get
pool requests in and build up their
portfolios with you know legitimate and
helpful contributions to this project
and all the other projects that we work
on okay so that was a lot of intro oh no
oh no I you would only see my face the
whole time I'm sorry everyone I'm sorry
I didn't have OBS like it was behind
some other stuff so I couldn't tell all
right sorry buddy real quick
this is what I was talking about these
entire items now are linked so you used
to have to click on just the text now
it's a link
this now is cursor:pointer and that's
pretty much that's pretty much it I had
showed that the last three pull requests
if you want to see him there
the last three closed pull requests in
the repo I'm really sorry about that
that was bad that was a long time of me
showing things so apologies to everyone
and John mentioned my gray beard hairs
again so I I deserve that one for for
making you all stare at my face while I
was thought I was showing you my screen
okay oh cool so Joey's Joey did the pool
of those last three pool crests and he's
here Joey thank you so much those were
just like perfect exactly what I wanted
I really liked it and some of the
solutions were totally different than
how I thought I would solve it and I
really liked it
especially how you when you put in the
code here I'll show you just quickly how
I did this so in a in our CSS our new
CSS that we're importing here we
basically wanted to keep all the CSS and
my thought was well let's make a whole
nother stylesheet and import it here and
this is so much more simple
he just said on the root component and
putted this in for all BR tags did
display unset that's awesome I didn't
even know you could do unset but really
cool I think that's oh it's so much
better than than what I was thinking of
doing so I really love that that's one
of the big benefits for me of having to
review pull requests I learned so many
good techniques from you all what I'm
trying to review the pull requests I
read pretty much every line of every
pull request so now I'm not talking
about like NPM packages and stuff that
you pull in of course I'm not reading
that but like the actual code that was
at it I definitely you know check that
all right so now cool Joey says it was
my first open source contribution other
than just fixing Doc's awesome
congratulations congratulations I'm
really happy for you Joey you didn't
text
job so you should you should definitely
be proud of your your first you know
code contribution okay so let's go to
our search component in our last episode
we were working on this search component
and we got it working to the point where
we could search for a certain keyword
and it would search across multiple post
types in our WordPress database and
using the WordPress REST API we would
get the results back as a JSON file and
then we would map over those results and
display the titles of each one of those
posts that that matched our keyword so
now what we would want to do is well two
things definitely need to happen right
away one we need to figure out why we're
only getting ten results no matter what
word we put in so it's probably
something that I need to add to our to
our string to our URL where we're you
know sending our requests and secondly
we need to make a better looking user
interface for this search right now it's
a very basic search bar and the search
button or not stout at all and the
results aren't aren't styled so today
will be more about the styling whereas
last the last episode the last stream
was more about the mechanics of how are
we going to format our query and get the
data back now we're gonna try to make
that data look nice
I do I see some questions in there so I
just want to let you all know if you've
asked a question I will get to those
questions as soon as or my timer goes
off here this Pomodoro timer
okay so let's actually let's try to go
to that search page no it's not working
anymore
what's up with this phase cannot be
property data of no
hmm
that's weird alright let's check out our
page here and see what we're doing
okay maybe it's trying to read the data
here and we don't have it so alright so
we're gonna try to do a check here first
then see if that exists No
okay so say we have stayed at all did we
even initial I know we didn't States
data
let's just initialize data as didn't
plan on starting this with an error
search gives an error in masters well
let's see okay I think it has something
to do with at the very end of the
episode keep saying episode it's we need
to say that the end of the last stream
we were already on that page and we are
grabbing data without a page refresh and
I think that was it like it didn't there
was always data there in state so it
wasn't causing an error but now that
we've just tried to load it again and
state is basically empty then we're
getting the error so I cannot refer you
Tate oh no I think my check is wrong and
I should've let's see I need to go back
and look how I check for similar things
previously since I for some reason just
can't remember how I do it
and spread it in zero right
I don't know I already was doing the
check you're right
Nicky I already had a ternary there I
already was checking for this state data
but it wasn't working there we go okay
now it works I believe the problem was
that I didn't actually have anything
here for data so at some point that
state does get set but down here it was
trying to check to see hey if if if this
say data exists you know then move on
but there was anyway you get what I'm
saying right so we forgot to initialize
our state within just data but just
having it be an empty array so let's
let's just test this verify that's
working and there's no more bugs before
we move on so just do a simple word yep
all right cool
so it is working here's what it would
gave us alcohol the titles I'm gonna do
a refresh yep okay again yep awesome it
works so sorry I gotta change my Spotify
okay
michael says you need to knock on your
wall and tell him to keep it down can
you hear there is a conversation going
on right outside my door to my office so
apologies for the noise there all right
so let's style let's tie our search bar
first we'll get that search looking
better actually do you even want that
I don't think we need alright let me
know what you think do we want a
separate search bar on the search page
or is it enough to just have a search
bar here or here I mean I I guess on
mobile I can see an advantage to having
another search bar because you would
actually I mean either way you'd
actually have to click again let me know
what you think yeah so what I'm gonna
hold off on styling this for now I'll
leave it there but I'm not gonna style
it if we end up deciding we don't even
need another search bar so for now I'm
gonna try to give these just some basic
style and try to get more than 10 to
show up and where is this I think I can
look let me look at a previous project
because I know we use this previously
and we got more than 10 results for sure
so we're going to go to this
catechetical Institute site where we
pulled some code from before and where
we pages resources and let's see what
we're using here there we are so we have
this per page 100 so let's put that in
here
let's save it and now we go back here
let's try it again
there we are okay so now we're getting a
lot more so essentially we can get 100
results back now so we don't even have a
hundred piece of content we're gonna
eventually I think we'll have to think
about like do we really want a hundred
results should we go like 20 at a time
and then give the option to load more
you know do what do we want to go with
like infinite scroll style I mean these
are all things that we will have to
decide but we don't have to decide right
now so I just want to bring them up so
that we can all think about them but
what a better user experience would be
and then we can try it out and it you
know it's one of those things that could
easily be changed down the road where we
know if we get feedback from real users
you know could definitely do something
you know differently okay
I check my time all right about six
minutes so let's see what we can do with
six minutes of your styling some of this
first thing we'll do is let's grab
another component and pull it in here
these are probably going to be these
will be cards
let's think how we want to display these
alright let's just let's go with
something really simple for now I think
I'm gonna do I'm not gonna try to use an
existing component just now originally
my idea was to have this all like you
know cards of multiple columns of cards
but I have a different idea now I think
I'm gonna make the search results look
more like like a Google search or
something similar a users are I think
more familiar and comfortable with that
so that's what I'm gonna go with for
this that also frees us up a bit because
with the cards I know if I do the card
style I'm gonna get feedback from other
people here at the University of you
know can we put some images or some
video in there then that's that's just
going to be a little bit extra you know
more things to handle more things to
load and I don't know that that would
necessarily enhance the experience we
could certainly have one type of search
that's a video search or an image search
that we can have that content but I
don't like the idea of mixing the
content together and having it display
if that does pilot can see it in my head
hopefully that makes a little bit of
sense but it's difficult to make just
text content look good if it's in this
kind of masonry layout alongside
primarily video content or image content
you end up depending on the screen with
it just looks weird so I'm gonna try it
like this I'm gonna stop talking and try
it just try to do something now so let's
see yeah I'm in the right spot so right
now we just have divs each one of these
is a div what we're gonna want to do now
though is so we want to keep this as the
title certainly
yeah let's let's keep this as the div
here but then let's make this let's go
the mage I'm just gonna make this a span
for now
and we're gonna call this class name
title whoops classes title whoops there
we go
what does that classes it's not define
yeah we didn't define it
let's forward some classes
oops I put that in the wrongs now that
was the right spot but then I also need
to bring in with styles
ten how you do this what am I doing
wrong
yeah I'm messing this all up
alright let me just go back for now what
am I missing from these other pages with
style styles
I'm bringing in I bring this in oops
with styles and now maybe this will be
better
so don't need a data let's see with
styles
shoot food is the with root here do I
need this
let's see alright
Jilly saying maybe export default with
rude with style stuff it alright let's
try that alright let's try that
okay cool oops yeah use one okay now
we're getting classes is not the fun all
right my timer went up went off so we're
gonna get this working when I get back
and here's why this isn't working
I never defined classes okay so I'll
define classes when we get back taking a
break is nice because when I stop trying
to look for the problem and I took three
seconds to take a break I realized I
never defined it that's why it's saying
it's undefined of course all right I'm
gonna go to the top of the live chat and
answer the first questions first see how
far we can get down the the chat gospel
says I'm just a beginner in programming
I had a study C C++ Java but I couldn't
no coding till now okay cool um I think
that you're saying that this stream is
helping you learn how to code effective
coding so that's awesome I'm really glad
if that's the case what you're saying
I'm really really glad that that helps
you out so thanks for watching feel free
to ask any questions
step 7 it's ste pienso Stepan says hello
Jesse I'd like to ask how to learn how
to integrate HTML to WordPress how did
you learn doing this
where'd I learn about this I guess there
weren't really a lot of tutorials
available when I started to learn I'm
assuming you're talking about using the
WordPress API like this I started using
the API before it was a part of
press corps so kind of early on and they
were on version two at that point so it
wasn't like right at the beginning but I
just read through the documentation and
tried to find any info I could on on
blogs and things like that and then just
tested things out so it was kind of it
was kind of tough honestly at first
there's a lot more information now yeah
but I was just kind of you know kept
trying out so you definitely need to
know how to make you know requests to
the API so whether you want to use you
know Ajax
or fetch or Axios or you know something
like that so learn how to make requests
API
you know calls with JavaScript and then
WordPress installs come automatically
with the API now so you can get data
right off the bat you know with any
wordpress site that is up to date
Mayor s why won't you develop this site
using WordPress or laravel or it's just
personal preference well we are kind of
so we're using WordPress for the content
management and we're pulling data from
there I prefer the front-end and you
know all the things that the user ends
up seeing and is not wordpress i my
wordpress i think is great for a lot of
use cases but if your goal is to make a
site that's very versatile and fast as
well as having the capability to be a
progressive web app I don't think
WordPress is the easiest system to use
so that's why I like to go with react
react has a lot of those capabilities
and depending on how you build it with
next or create react app a lot of those
capabilities come built in so it it
gives me a lot more freedom to more
quickly change things and add features
than it would if I worked with WordPress
now if I was very skilled with PHP it
might be easier for me to change a
wordpress theme but I'm Way more
experienced with JavaScript than I am
with PHP so this this worked well for me
and I like the fact that my data is
decoupled from my the rest of my my
front end there because it gives me the
ability to pull in data from different
sources
- totally migrated to something else if
I wanted to either with the front end or
the back end because they're not tightly
coupled like normally in a wordpress
install if you do things normally with
themes you know the look of your site
and your WordPress installation are all
together so it would be very difficult
to say like hey I love other site looks
but you know what I don't want to use
WordPress anymore for this I want to
switch to
let's say Drupal well essentially that
means you're going to completely rebuild
your site and have to transfer all your
data I mean I guess you could
potentially say no you have to if you
didn't like if you like the look but you
didn't want to deal with the WordPress
back-end you'd have to redo your whole
site this way what we could do is say ok
let's transform press data somewhere
else and just pull it into the site just
like we were doing before might have to
change a few things in where we're
making the API calls but essentially
your site can remain to you from a
user's point of view exactly the same
even though everything behind the scenes
has changed yeah so those are some of
the benefits that I see from having them
decoupled or not doing it kind of the
traditional WordPress way all right
obviously as you can see my timers up
let's see where I'm leaving off
I mean just write down where we're
leaving off so I can go right back there
okay all right let's go back I do need
to take a drink I have a new G fuel
shaker by the way so G fuel if you're
watching sponsor me this is the New York
comic-con shaker which I got for free
for ordering G fuel when there was a
sale or something some reason today abs
like super thirsty my mouth is dry
truthfully I think I'm like right on the
the verge of being sick I did take some
pain medicine because my throat is
starting to hurt and kind of swell up so
I didn't want it to be a problem for the
stream so it took some pain medicine but
that's all why you make it through to
the weekend I have I have another
presentation tomorrow and I need to give
that presentation and then I'll be okay
I don't know if I'll be able to stream
tomorrow though actually because my wife
is going on a retreat this weekend so
she's gonna be gone overnight on Friday
and get back at some point Saturday
evening so I need to get out early and
get the kids from her and then pick up
my older ones from school and my older
ones are gonna spend the night at my
parents house on Friday so I will still
have the baby so it's going to be kind
of weird for me to just that me and the
baby at home so we'll see how that goes
I mean I'm I'm perfectly capable of
taking care of the baby but it's just so
weird to have like an empty house okay
what did I break before we left off
another I broke something
hello okay this these classes right so
let's just pull in well yet am I not
using no I'm not using it here where am
I using it here classes I guess it would
have been faster for me not to try a
copy and paste that Oh
don't need these all right let's see if
that works
yeah that works
awesome let's get rid of that mess okay
so now we can't use these these classes
so we're gonna make for now just two
spans we're gonna make probably make
this atone component at some point there
may have been something in material UI
that would work better for this like a
list component maybe we should use that
let me just try this first and then
maybe we can check out the mature UI
documentation quickly to see if there's
something pre-made that might be better
for us to use rendered so we need to set
a title rendered we need excerpt
I don't know if we have suitable
excerpts for everything we're gonna find
out here in a second
Wow okay Wow
hmm I was not thinking that we would get
HTML tags in with our excerpt didn't
really want that
okay yeah Joey says need dangerously
said innerhtml
yeah I am yeah that's what we need to
display that properly I I think I don't
want the HTML to be rendered so that's
this kind of a problem with the data
right now there may be a better way in
WordPress that I could strip out the
tags there hmm yeah often work on that
WordPress so for now I will display
these until like as is so I'm gonna do a
little bit of styling here
so let's go title we're gonna make this
font size 24 pixels it's got 24 pixels
font weight font weight is 400 and I'm
messing this up there we go and then
let's go and then excerpt is gonna be
font size 18 pixels and then weight
we're gonna set to 300 okay now let's
see what kind of a difference this makes
this phone is here Johannes why do we
have this in here
sake get rid of that okay so this is a
little bit easier to see where
everything is wow that's huge for an
excerpt yeah Wow
I'm gonna have some serious data cleanup
to do if we're gonna be able to do this
search like I wanted to
Wow
michael says at this point we wouldn't
blame you for cursing your predecessors
yeah alright how are we gonna handle
this okay here's what I'm thinking right
now we can't rely on the excerpt or
content to be in any type of format that
it needs to be in I don't think I'll
have time but I still don't have a date
for launch so I don't know I don't know
when we're gonna launch I need to be
kind of ready to launch let's say at the
end of this month but we could
realistically have two more months I
don't know so let's say I only have till
the end of this month before we launch I
don't think there's any way that I can
go through every piece of content and
clean this up or even add in an extra
field of my own type of description I
can't do that so I think we're gonna
have to just stick with the titles of
the pieces of content
yeah it's got to be that so we should
have alright let's have the data that we
can have this should be somewhat decent
the titles they will need some work but
that's a lot easier than changing large
chunks of text so I I probably would
have time to go through and change
titles and then the content type so we
can display the content type and the
title in between those things perhaps we
can give the user enough information
alright let's do that the third thing
that we need to worry about that I don't
think will solve today's where do we
then send the user right
like what right now WordPress has no
idea what the page URLs are so when we
display this do we are we trying then to
send the user to a page and the site or
would we want to just display the full
content to the user I mean they're gonna
expect to go to a page right yeah I mean
I think we need some way to link up the
main place where a piece of content
would exist on the page to a URL
based on a content type we should be
able to do that okay I just want to get
that out there so we can think about it
I'm not gonna try to solve that problem
today what we are gonna do today is try
to pull in content type and let's try to
pull in well we already have the titles
we're actually we're going to need to
put the titles in through what's the
dangerousness at enter HTML because we
have special characters like this that
won't display without it alright so
let's do that let's do that now let's
get rid of this and instead put item
I think it's type so item type and then
let's go to to uppercase is a thing
right to up for kids so it is alright
and instead of this let's put let's call
this type and let's change this a bit
type and we're gonna make this I guess
that's fine we didn't really have to do
to uppercase there we could have done it
in CSS yeah let's get let's get rid of
this because let's do it in the CSS the
reason I'm going to do this is because
this is gonna come through kind of weird
and actually it's probably going to have
some hyphens in it so we may need to
pull those out but for now let's do text
this text transform yeah text transform
there's an uppercase or capitalized I
think it's uppercase and then for this
we need to do dangerously set enter HTML
it's an HTML like that yeah equals and
then what are we doing in here is it
double
I think it's double I always have to
look this up HTML and I think this is
how you do it okay that looks all right
and we do that we don't need this here
anymore you can just close that tag okay
all right
okay so yeah I did something with the
dangerously set innerhtml they said it
okay so it is capitalized I was right
the first time so yeah I definitely want
yeah I'm gonna need we're gonna need to
transform these somehow at the very
least I want the send me my door no I
think they're just unloading equipment
right in front of my door we need to
remove the hyphens but I'm not worried
about that for now I just want to get
this displaying oops no must be in the
form of oh I need double double these
yeah all right cool so now we have the
special characters this fling and now we
know what the type is all right
wonderful all right let's check
I'm checking the live chat just to see
if anyone had any suggestions about what
you were just doing Joey says react HTML
parser might be better practiced and
dangerously set in our HTML yeah you're
right that could be better
usually when I have like when I have
control over what data's being pulled in
it's coming from from sources they
really like media people my team are
gonna be the only people who have access
to I don't worry about it as much but in
general you're right it is a good it
would be a better practice to use
something a bit more secure
I Nicky's trying to get my attention
would is let's see
alright I'm not sure what was going on
all right so this is not shake my time
seven minutes yeah this is not really
good looking we could make it a bit
better I did say we were gonna check out
the material UI documentation so let's
let's do that quickly now I think I
missed I want to see what that pop-up
was no anyway demos
there's a list yeah it's not really what
I want not the grid let's see what the
expansion panels look like yeah I don't
think I want expansion panels here
that's pretty cool
okay so I think we're good with what we
have what I'd like to do is add some
space between these maybe maybe even
will try space it first so okay John was
trying to get my attention so what let
somebody see what's up John okay mark
down to JSX will work what all right so
what are we what are we gonna use
markdown to JSX for
let me know why we should use markdown
to JSX
I'm not I haven't used it before okay so
I want to move this up
and let's make
let's call this classes starts search
results so for our search results let's
go with margin
all right let's check that out see what
it gives us okay
a little bit more space you can
definitely tell what's what
actually this entire thing needs to be
placed in our kind of grid that we've
had on other pages so
constant continue let's shout out let's
pull this content container out of here
and just try it over here on the search
and see what we have
layouts
he puts this
yeah
shh-shh alright so this is just some
like basic layout styling right now we
just want to wrap the container or we
want to have a container around all of
this
he was from oops I was using theme is
not defined what's I can't use theme
I gotta put theme in here okay and my
timer is going off now I'll see if that
did it No
area okay so now we have a little bit of
space there so that looks nicer so
basically we just we added this
container that gives us various widths
depending on how large the screen is
that's where these theme break points
came into play so these are built into
material UI so when we bring in theme
we're able to use those built in break
points and you can see we we made a
container out of this div that just
contains all that basically everything
on our page
you know except the the app bar all
right so that's that's as far as I think
we're going to get today you can see
basically where I'm kind of going with
this is that we will have clearly marked
content types and then titles right now
the titles are a bit of a mess but we
are going to clean those up and yeah so
I think it'll be we're gonna have to add
a link to link users to a page that they
can get more information obviously and
then we still need to create a bunch of
ways to sort the data and filter the
data okay
so let me just let's commit this then
I'll go to the live chat answer any
questions that anyone has to get an oops
yarn see oh I apologize this font was
probably a bit too small for you all
sorry about that
so it's
yeah that's pretty much it
[Music]
okay great that passed ooh kids push all
right so all the changes are now in
github and I'm gonna scroll back up to
where we left off at in the live chat
and I'm also gonna take off my sweater
it's really hot in here I don't want to
turn on the fan and you know have all
that extra noise so excuse me a second
it's not even really cold enough for a
sweater here I don't know what I was
thinking when I wore this today okay so
we left off
now michael has said just got here no
Ambridge today ya know Amber's today if
you watch the stream that I did
yesterday on on my youtube channel my
son Ambrose was there he's three and
then my daughter Cordelia is one I'm
gonna one-and-a-half something like that
was also in the in the video my wife may
have made it on I don't know if she made
it on camera or not she was in the room
and so it got a little crazy with with
the kids there and at one point Ambrose
was running behind me with just the
shirt on and nothing else he went to the
bathroom and couldn't put his underwear
back on luckily it did not get on camera
alright let's get I'm just growing down
now looking for questions
while it says for search page autofocus
the input bar that is a great idea I
definitely definitely want to do that I
think that's that's an awesome feature
the website can I use does that and I
love it every time I go there I I
noticed that and I'm so thankful that it
just saves me a click and usually when I
go to can I use like I know exactly what
I'm looking for I just want to look at
it really fast it's perfect so yeah I
definitely want to do that that's a
great idea
smiler says hi cool beard when I saw you
last time you were without a beard I was
I was that was probably a while back a
couple months ago at least yeah so right
now I have have the beard I'm thinking
maybe I'll keep it for a while I kind of
thought about shaving it recently I
don't know let me know what you think
should I keep the beard should I shave
it I don't know why I'm thinking about
shaving it may I'm just getting bored
with it but let me know what y'all think
michael says you don't need a search
page you just need a search results page
yeah I mean I I agree but you know
essentially a search page in the search
results page you're going to be the same
thing it's just going to be a page
wherever you display results you know
the only question is are we gonna have
another search for or not either way I
mean that the page is going to look
almost exactly the same
I think there's a discussion about
buying laptop versus desktops and
different things so I'm not going to
read through all that hopefully if this
new feature works like it's supposed to
on YouTube you all that watch this later
will be able to read through that
discussion as well trade Oz says hi
Jesse your thoughts on typescript I have
not used tight script myself
I mean I've like read over it in some
repos they use it
I think typescript is a cool idea I
could see how it would be useful
I don't like it enough for me to use it
but I haven't really had a lot of
experience with it so I could see why
typescript could potentially be a better
way to do things so I wouldn't adopt
tight script like across the board but
potentially like for a specific project
it might not be a bad idea to require
typescript on on a project yeah so I
don't know I kind of think it's so it's
correct me if I'm wrong but the
typescript could potentially I don't
like it it makes your code I don't know
how to say this so this is my take on
Titan script like I said maybe I maybe
I'm wrong I don't know a lot about it
but typescript is basically a more
strongly typed version of JavaScript I
mean it's it's still JavaScript right
but it's it's like this layer on top so
potentially typescript would have the
same advantages as a strongly typed
language it would be harder to write bad
code or insecure code so that's why I'm
thinking like depending on the project
if you really needed you know that those
type of safeguards I could see it as
being important but on most projects I'd
prefer to use regular JavaScript
it'd be accessible for more people to be
able to read the code and contribute so
anyway that's my thoughts and if I'm
totally missing the point of typescript
please let me know I guess I I have not
done that much with it and I've seen
very little typescript code so I could
be getting it completely wrong see
michael says this stream reminds me that
I'm not the only geek in the world of
course I get upset at my son when he
only watches youtube videos with people
doing things instead of doing things so
here I am Nietzsche says how you updated
the branch you used for a pull request
when updates happened to the master
branch while you're working on it
something with a git rebase or as simple
as a pool what would be the best way can
you let me think yeah I guess you'd have
to update your your fork with the new
stuff and I can't remember I did this
like sometime within the last month and
I can't remember how I did it I totally
how did I do that it's not something I
do enough that I remember and I always
have to look it up so yeah I mean I
would assume however you normally update
your fork that's what you would do and
just make sure that your particular
branch gets updated with with the new
stuff as well
michael says d fuel when react drains
all your health John says I've heard
Django is a good alternative to
WordPress I've I haven't worked with
Django I've heard it talked about a lot
or mentioned a lot I don't really know
whether or not like it really is it
really would be an alternative to
WordPress or it exists kind of in a
different class so from what I
understand Django would be like it's a
PHP framework or library so Django might
be to PHP what like angular is to
JavaScript something like that I don't I
don't know if that comparison is correct
exactly but yeah so it seems to me
though that Jenga would take a lot more
knowledge about coding to use and
WordPress you don't have to know
anything about coding to use WordPress
if you really just wanted to so that's
why I think WordPress might be in a
different class and ennis it's Enes and
it says why don't you put semicolons so
I'm using JavaScript style guide it's
called like standard style so standard
yes and you don't need to use semicolons
with that so they're all they're very
few and rare cases where you actually
need a semicolon or else it changes the
meaning of your code so of course in
those cases I would most certainly use a
semicolon but I've never come across one
of those cases in my code not that I can
remember so I prefer not to use
semicolons because given the choice
between writing more and that more doing
nothing or writing less
of course I will choose to write less
but I'm cool with people who like
semicolons so this is your entirely free
tool of semicolons are not in this live
chat
michael says the difference this is the
difference between front-end and
back-end devs the front-end devs want to
make it look good the back-end devs want
it to be right yeah yeah and I'm like
stuck in between right now so I I want
it to look good MB right let's see Jeff
says can you limit the display text to a
certain length
I can we could definitely limit the text
for now though I think I'm gonna try to
just not have the text because I mean
the date is not in good shape I'm not
even sure that all of our data like all
of our posts even have Xers I mean we
could just pull in the actual text and
this give a little bit of it but I I
don't know I think it's going to be
weird I'd rather show less and have that
less look better then just dump a bunch
of stuff on the page that potentially
might not even make sense
see
Joey says there's probably an HTML
parser package that could be used I did
something like that with Python a few
years ago yeah yeah for sure and I think
someone mentioned it a little later on
in the stream michael says don't do it
don't do it was it when I was putting in
danger as I said enter HTML it's not
quite as dangerous as it sounds as long
as you for sure know what's going to be
put into that that element well Jeff had
mentioned putting a link to the page and
your attire you're right that definitely
needs to go in there
josephus is this Quincy no this is
Jessie I just volunteer for free code
camp camp Quincy is the man in charge so
occasionally he does stop in and in the
live chat but I don't think he's
watching today
michael says was the search a big
problem in your previous meeting if not
why stress it did come up in one of the
meetings think yeah you know and I don't
remember exactly what we what I even
said about it in the meeting but I just
know so the search is a feature that we
definitely want oh I know
I remember now how it came up yes so it
is it did come up there right now people
weren't happy with the current search
and you know they want it to be better
so I did talk a little bit about how the
search was going to function so I need
to you know come through with that at
some point the reason I'm focusing on
the search right now is because when I'm
not streaming I need to be moving data
over and getting it in better shape
which is pretty boring so I'm trying to
do things on the stream that I don't
know a little bit more interesting and
have some kind of immediate visual
feedback so I think that that's better
for streaming so that's why I'm working
on the search stuff right now
it may not be a hundred percent
necessary right now at this point but
it's definitely a feature that I think
we should have for launch people are
going to expect the search
okay so John was mentioning markdown -
JSX a while ago and I had asked him to
explain more about it so he says
markdown - JSX will make the HTML markup
read as JSX markup even though you're
bringing it over that string of HTML
okay yeah you're right that that would
make sense
John says you wouldn't have to bring
over all the content but maybe a preview
of the first few sentences or so as it
shows in the search results yeah
Nietzsche says yeah strip the HTML tags
from the excerpt and truncate the
excerpt
Michels say did I do the pull request
right what pull request did you do pull
request through this repo did I miss it
or are we talking about a different repo
let me know
okay Joey says I didn't use yarn cm I'm
guessing I should use that for all
future commits yeah Joe please use yarn
cm for four commits it's it's okay it's
not like a huge deal but we're trying to
keep kind of a standard commit message
structure so yeah try to use that next
time oh excuse me
he says get that go time for lots of
french fries bye everyone please give me
feedback on the PR and get up okay I
will try my best to look over that pull
request and get you feedback sometime
today if I can and Wow
I really wish I had lots of french fries
I'm kind of hungry right now
Oh John Hanson says focus on an employee
input field will not work and react when
set in the HTML input element has to be
set in j/s though it can be buggy
depending on what else is announcing and
how many other listeners are in use okay
that's good to know so that that will
not be as easy as I thought it would be
okay
oh I need to correct something I said
earlier so Joey and Nino tell me that
Django is a Python framework my
apologies I was mixing up Django with
laravel sorry about that so for whatever
reason I mix up Python or Django and
Largo so Django is a framework for
Python and then if you want a PHP
framework laravel is the way to go so
that's the better comparison so
comparing I believe and maybe I'm wrong
on this too please let me know so
comparing Django to WordPress I don't
think is necessarily like an exact
comparison there but laravel and Django
would be a better comparison let me know
disclaimer here I haven't worked with
any of those frameworks so please don't
take my word for this I I haven't taken
the time to learn about any of this oh I
brush it and just say shouldn't say
anything I don't want to mislead anyone
ok Michael's talking about the node
Resource Manager rebo oh ok Oh
Michael off to check that out so I've
kind of been like honestly I've kind of
been putting that stuff on the back
burner burner since I already turned it
in and I've had you know a lot of
requests coming in for this project and
then we have that Java Script AF side
project as well which I'm finally
starting to actually you'll get ready to
do some work on because I haven't had
time so apologies oh I'll try to take a
look at that
as soon as I can alright well I am to
the bottom of the live chat so thank you
everyone for watching and for all your
help and your advice definitely
I definitely got a lot of good opinions
I always like that gives me a lot to
think about and the end result always
ends up being way better than what I
intended I might be back tomorrow
tomorrow I got a short day and I have a
presentation I can't remember what time
my presentation is so if I do stream
tomorrow it may be at a weird time maybe
not at our normal time but yeah so make
might see tomorrow maybe maybe next week
either way I hope you all have a great
day maybe a great weekend
and hopefully I see y'all back here for
the next stream or will work again on
this search function all right thanks
again see ya